i'm going to talk about the the post
office try or sometimes called
the post office scandal this was about
um the post office in the uk
um they obviously deal with selling
stamps but they're also
part of everyday life in the uk so they
deal with
driving licenses um taxes
um they're a bank for many people they
pay out pensions
and so there's actually a lot of money
flowing through these branches
and it turned out that there
were many people who were running these
branches
who were accused of stealing money or at
least losing money sometimes tens of
thousands of pounds
some were prosecuted and a few even went
to jail and it turned out that
horizon the computer system that post
office use does have
a lot of bugs and these bugs could have
been responsible for some of these
losses
and so the people who are running these
branches called subpostmasters
largely won that case now we never got
to the bottom of exactly what happened
to these individuals the court case was
settled
before that stage of the trial
progressed but we do know the sorts of
problems that
affected horizon and the sort of
challenges that there are
in building a system of this type
this was a huge news story uh in the uk
i listened to a great podcast which i'll
probably link in the description from
the bbc
explaining a little bit about some of
these people and what happened to them
but they didn't really explain what
sorts of things went wrong this money's
gone missing
you know you're going to jail because
you've lost this money where was this
money
did the money exist yeah so
what horizon is as an accounting system
and if you could imagine
how you might build something like this
let's suppose you take a simple case
where you have
a shop and they just have a bucket which
they use for keeping the money
and then a bucket which they use for
looking after their products we can call
these stamps because it's a post office
each time someone takes in some money
they put the money in the bucket
and then they give out some of these
stamps or whatever they're trying to
sell
that works like this is how you might
run a lemonade stall or something like
that
it's okay but it's got a number of
problems so one is that you don't
actually know
how much money you've got and also you
don't know how much stock
you've got so you might want to do
something better than that now let's
build in some raker keeping so if you're
running a more sophisticated limb needs
stand
you might do this here you have a table
and then
in this table you put in your sales
and you might say oh one pound worth of
stamps and then you might
sell six pounds worth of stamps and at
the end of the day
you add this up and then you found out
that you have
earned seven pounds for that day so
again that's good but what this doesn't
tell you
is the amount of stock you have so what
you might then do is add another column
to this
and if you start the day with 100 stamps
then
you sell one pound worth of stamps and
if each stamp is worth one pound
now you've got 99 pounds and then you
sell
six pounds worth of stamps now you go
from 99 down to
93 and then at the end of the day you've
got 93 stamps
and then once that starts getting close
to zero then you can start saying
okay maybe it's time to buy some more
there's still some problems here
one is the people who are running these
desks
in the post office are sometimes not
employees of the the post office
and maybe you want to see that they're
not making mistakes so you can actually
build
two books so you've still got your sale
and still your your stock
but then you've got a separate book
which is the the stock
at the the central office this could
start off
with zero and then you give out
100 stamps so this is now down
100 and that is up 100
and then at the end of the day maybe
the person who's running this decides
that they don't want to
keep all those stamps they're going to
keep three of them so they're going to
hand back 90 so then this goes down to 3
and this goes down to plus 90
and then the total of this is going to
be
minus 10. we now get this a nice
property that if we
add up all the totals seven pounds worth
of stamps
three left in the stock and we've got
minus 10 over here
that equals zero and the fact it should
always equal zero
if you do this thing called double
injury accounting and that's the check
that is used
but what happened in these subpostmaster
cases is it didn't add up to zero
it added up to less than zero and the
way the contract was set up
between the post office headquarters and
the
individual post offices was that the
people running the post offices were
responsible
for this amount of money so it looked
like money disappeared
and the post office accused them of
putting this in their back pocket
and then they had to pay this back in
some cases sometimes they went to jail
um sometimes both you see how this could
go wrong quite quickly in quite a huge
way and be very difficult to work out
where it went yeah it's millions of
transactionality
computers don't make mistakes though
right isn't that the isn't that the
thing
yeah so that's um roughly what the post
office said that um this is a simple
problem
um it's uh easy for computers to to do
the right thing it's just adding and
subtracting and the numbers are not very
hard really if you look at other videos
in computer file there's far more
sophisticated problems and computers
seem to do
reasonably well at that but there's a
few challenges i mentioned that
the numbers should always add up to zero
and the reason they always add up to
zero is for
every positive number you add into the
system
there's a negative number that you're
taking away and
these two things have got to happen um
always
but if for example the computer fails
when it's doing half of that transaction
then you get a shortfall and this is
a known problem in computing and what
you want is something called
transactions and in a transaction
either everything happens in a
transaction so
in addition and subtraction both happen
or none of it happens
and if it doesn't happen you you know
about it and you can deal with it
so sometimes the decrement acid comes up
so
this stands for atomicity so that means
it can't be broken up so either all that
happens
or none of it happens and there's
consistency
and that is that the properties you want
are always
true so for example you want things to
always add up to
to zero you want everything to the same
synchronization
there's also isolation and this means
that no matter what's happening in one
part of the system it shouldn't
cause failures in other parts of the
system because these post offices are
not just one computer sitting in a desk
there's the computer there's the backup
there might be several desks there's a
post office headquarters computer and
and all that
and then durability is the the final
part
and that means that once something has
happened you actually know what's
happened has definitely happened
so you don't need to then go back and
check whether it has accidentally been
undone by something else
going on the system so this is what the
post office system
should have and it did have measures to
try to do this
but over the millions of transactions
it's doing every day some of these
things went wrong
if we take an example of atomicity so
what this means is that things happen
exactly one time once and only once but
sometimes things went wrong we had a
case that was brought up in the trial
where you had two desks and these have
the computer
system but they've also got a drawer
full of money and
for for whatever reason it's sometimes
necessary to to move money between them
because maybe one's paying out
most of the time one's taking money in a
lot of the time so that they get
imbalanced
and you want to move some money about so
they move the money
in between these two terminals but then
the computer recorded
one then something went wrong and then
it duplicated
so now the computer thinks there's
twice as much money in this terminal
than there should be
and that triggers one of these
imbalances so that's estimate the other
one is consistency consistency means
that everything matches
so if something happens at one side
something happens at the other side
and again that went wrong horizon is one
system
but like most fake systems it's actually
built out of lots of components
so there's one component for actually
running
the disk that the subpostmasters and
their staff interact with
but there's other one for actually
keeping track of the money it's a
standard accounting package
and horizon dealing with the counters
should stay
in sync with the accounting system
but it turned out in one case it didn't
so if a
user was um dealing with one system and
then they press cancel at just the wrong
time
then that transaction would appear in
horizon but would not appear in the
accounting system
so again you've got the case of you've
got an inconsistency
that can show up as a shortfall and then
the subpostmaster can get blamed for
that
next one is is isolation that means that
if something happens in one system
it shouldn't interfere with something on
the double system
and again we saw the case of where that
went wrong so here
a subpostmaster was um printing out a
report
showing how much money was taken in how
much stock was used in one day
and then if in the process of printing
out this report
another counter in this branch
did a transaction that transaction would
not appear in the report
so again you'd have something happening
to the stock
something happening to the money but not
showing up in the report and again
you've got
one of these uh fuel reserve consistency
and then the final one is durability so
that means that when something happens
it's actually going to happen
and there's no way of undoing it so
again
that's been seen to go wrong so here
there was
a customer who um withdrew some money
from their bank but you can do this in
the post office
and the transactions seem to go
through fine a receipt was printed the
customer got the cash
but then the receipt printed out
recovery failed
so recovery is the thing that horizon
does and
many other systems do when something's
gone wrong
with one of these properties and they
then want to
correct the error but that didn't work
for whatever reason maybe a hardware
failure
and then the transactions just
disappeared so horizon
showed that the money was never
withdrawn from the bank
but the customer walked away with the
money um and now you've got a shortfall
in this case the subpostmaster was very
tenacious the subpostmaster
um found out where this customer was
maybe they knew each other and got them
to check their bank statement
and then it turned out that the money
had left the customer's bank account
it just never appeared in horizon and so
the customer obviously didn't really
want to give this money back from their
perspective
they'd taken out the money they'd
receive the cash but there was a short
fall at that branch and because of all
the evidence the subpostmaster
collected they were able to sort the
situation out but maybe in
different circumstances it wouldn't be
as easy and they seem like such
simple simple problems i mean what if
if something is there must have been
logs or something were there logs that
horizon was keeping could the you know
could they not check the logs as it were
there are logs in the system
and there's logs both in the
subpostmasters
domain so the their branch there's also
logs in post office headquarters and
actually makes things harder because now
you've got a distributed system
and distributed systems makes everything
harder so
imagine you've got your post office
counter over here
so this is inside the post office but
actually there's going to be
um probably more than one terminal in
these cases and these are connected up
with a network and then
you've got the post office headquarters
over here
and then they've got their computer
system for most of horizon history this
was before the internet was
commonly used and so they were not
permanently connected to each other over
the internet they are now what happens
is that
each of these post office terminals is
networked to each other and that's
permanently connected
but the connection to the headquarters
only happens every so often
and the way that they try to say
synchronize is that they have logs
each branch computer writes out a log
entry
and then what they try to do is then
make sure that everything has exactly
the same log
so they'll copy them over so that entry
will go there
that entry will go over here and so by
the end of this process
they will all have the the same entries
and
that's a problem called consensus and
that's actually quite hard to to solve
even in a fairly theoretical way when
you build this
on real hardware with um the connections
that fail
hardwares that fail uh then it becomes
even more challenging and a pattern that
seems to have
come up in this court case is that
problems
tended to occur when there was some
failure either communications failure or
hardware failure
so that might well have been a problem
in the way that this consensus algorithm
is working
in making sure the logs on each of these
terminals are synchronized
so as well as doing the the customer
facing things like printing receipts
um and helping the subpostmaster keep
track of things
the horizon system and associated
infrastructure also
keeps logs of modifications and
some of those modifications are
perfectly legitimate
so you might be doing some transactions
or you might be fixing problems
but if there's the wrong sort of
modification
then you end up with a serious problem
it could be
this would be what someone does to to
hide the fact that they're stealing some
money
so what the sort of thing you want from
an audit log
is you want to make sure that you know
exactly when something has happened you
want to know exactly what they did
you want to know who they are you also
want to make sure that not too many
people have
access to the system it should be server
on a need to know basis
and horizon does have that sort of thing
and
this is the evidence that actually was
used to
prosecute the subpostmasters who the
post office was claiming and stolen some
money
what they said is that at this
particular time um
someone using this terminal with this
password um
made this transaction and that
transaction was fraudulent and
one of the things that the post office
said um
in court and and also um in parliament
when they were questioned
is that only the subpostmaster in the
branch or
only the branch computer can modify
these logs
and this was a very contentious point in
the trial um there were some
fairly dramatic scenes about how this
was um discussed
but it turned out there were actually
quite a few problems with this log in
terms of when
sometimes the wrong time went into these
load injuries so that could cause some
confusion about
when um a person was actually in a
branch if they are blamed for something
there was also a question about
what had happened because in some cases
these logs were
not actually correct and then there was
who was actually doing it
so another disclosure was that actually
a lot of people
working for the post office and their
subcontractors had access to the system
more than probably should have and so
they in fact did have the ability
to remotely modify the system um
and the the logs that they kept of when
this would be happening and how this
would be happening
were not as good as you would hope and
also
it could make it appear that it was a
subpostmaster who had done something
when actually it was a either an
automatic change or
a manual change that was done by someone
else so
eventually the truth came out in this
trial um
and this was yet another thing that uh
made it dramatically more difficult for
the post office to say that
actually it was a subpostmaster's
responsibility when there was a
shortfall in a branch so this one goes
all the way over to here
this one goes over to here and so and so
on remember this is going to be
an iterative process and what we want to
do is move these things around
and there will be instructions about
transferring this money back to the
right person
but actually that's all fake the money
has not appeared in your account